merry Christmas happy New Year welcome
to the N stradamus crystal balls I am
here to bring my predictive powers to
Bear to give you my five I guess this
would be 10 five five each five big
predictions for 2024 I demonstrated my
powers of prediction last year I
predicted that Biden and the feds were
going to raid Trump so again a prophet
is not one who sees into the future so
much as a prophet is one who sees the
truth of the present and as a con quence
of that seems to predict the future well
here are my predictions number one Trump
will be the GOP nominee unless he
suffers some catastrophic health problem
I predict that Donald Trump will be the
GOP nominee in 2024 this is not a huge
prediction to make I'm not going that
far out on a limb because Trump is
leading the polls by something like 50
points and crucially he has been the
whole time so the polls just have not
moved over the past 16 months or however
long this primary is G on for there was
a moment where people thought maybe
maybe DeSantis will jump up or now
people are saying well maybe Haley will
jump up or oh Chris Christie he's going
to take down Trump that'll be the
chrysant it just hasn't happened my
second prediction is that there will be
a recession and the reason I'm
predicting this is not because I know
anything about the economy I don't the
only reason that I think that there will
be an economic recession is because Jim
Kramer on CNBC says there will not be a
recession and it is generally a good
strategy that when the CNBC Financial
guy says one thing assume the opposite
and so because Jim Kramer says there
won't be a recession I am saying save
your pennies because I think there will
be my third prediction AI deep fake porn
is going to become a political issue I
think that women who are victims of it
whose faces and even bodies perhaps are
being put into this kind of weird
computerized porn thing I think they're
going to start suing in court and I
think that legislators are going to take
up the issue and pass laws against it or
at least try to pass laws against it
probably the libs are going to stop them
from passing laws against it but I think
it is going to become a political issue
right now it seems like the craziest
most far-fetched
Fringe notion in the world no one's
really talking about it I think that not
only will it eventually become a
political issue I think it will in 2024
in part that's because AI just advances
so rapidly 10 months ago there was no
such thing as air we were just shocked
the moment we saw pictures being
generated by a computer in 60 seconds
that were impressive we were so amazed
by it even 8 months ago AI art it was
pretty good but it couldn't do fingers
certain things were really far off and
then in the span of four to 6 months all
of a sudden the AI art was just really
really good now the Deep fake videos are
really really good so because it
advances so rapidly I think it's going
to become a big problem and the people
who are going to be victims of it the
women are not necessarily just going to
be celebrities or public Figures it's
going to be the girl in your math class
I think it's going to be the girl that
sits across from you at work I think
it's going to be private individuals
because we have such a huge social media
footprint people are going to creeps are
going to grab pictures and things like
that plug them into the one of these AI
gizmos and and create not just deep
fakes that are generally anod it's going
to be as as all technological
developments with computers largely
focused around porn and it's going to be
super creepy and I think it's going to
be a political issue my fourth
prediction Hunter Biden will not face
any serious consequences for his crimes
he might be dragged in front of Congress
he might become a major topic of
conversation if his father is impeached
he will not face any serious
consequences is my prediction and here's
my final prediction we for another year
once again will not find out who is on
Epstein's Client List the most powerful
people on planet Earth all have a
profound interest in you and I not
finding out who is on Epstein's Client
List so that prediction that one goes
down just as easy as Jeffrey Epstein
will not have killed himself okay that's
it that's the n crystal ball we will
check in next year to see how right I
was